So here's the answer. We'll try it and see what we
get. And while it's running, let's think about what we should
get. So we can look at the examples that we did
so far and try to make some predictions. So we saw
when the value passed in was 10 to the 5, that
the time it took to execute was 0.005. When the time
passed in was 10 to the 6, so 1 million. We
saw that the time to execute was 0.05, and now we're trying
to predict 10 to the nine. If we look at
the pattern here, every time we increase n by a
factor of 10, the time also multiplies by a factor
of 10. And, that's not surprising because the loop is going
around ten more times. The times, number of times we
go through the loop, scales as a factor of the
input value n, so if we increase n by a
factor of 10, the time will also increase by a factor
of 10. And we see we have got our
result now, so if we increase by another factor
of 10, we would expect that this would also
increase, that it would take about half a second to
do 10 million. If we increased by another factor
of 10 we would expect the running time would
also multiple by 10, so we'd be up to
about 5 seconds. And if we increased by another factor
of 10 which is the billion that we tried, we'd
expect it to also increase by another factor of 10.
Getting to be something around 50 seconds. So it's not
exactly a 1,000 times what we had when we did
spin loop passing in a million, but it's pretty close
to that. Now it's taking almost a minute, 1,000 times
this would be 54 seconds, so it's a little bit
off from that. But very close, and if we tried it
a few more times, we might get a slightly different result.
Let's try is one more time. So we tried it again
and this time we got 55.89 seconds, pretty close to what
we got the previous time. The important point here is that
the running time depends on the value of the input to
spin loop and it depends on in a linear way. As
we increase the magnitude of n, the higher number of times
through the loop, the running time scales linearly with that value.